welcome to this video playing invincible
XE ok playing something different the
Lycans defense oops this guy has no name
pretty pretty it's not a very frequent
account let's see is playing the
exchange variation of the lake and
defense it's not the most ambitious line
but pretty pretty decent of course he's
some are not preventing Bishop g4 is
this something I don't know really
playing this by ear don't don't know
this opening too well of course you
should always try to make to put some
pressure on the center and this opening
so trying to do that d5 now it looks
fairly normal 97 f 5 is a typical way to
to to continue if I go ja if I move it
you might play even reform get get even
more space but my position is solid I
don't think that g4s such a big problem
ok nighty seven then G 45 wins apiece
that's not so great
maybe we treat this before it can get a
problem and night e 7 f5 or something
like that but it is not very active
right okay I can take this which is not
maybe one night at five yeah night f5
actually but I think I have to do this
anyway at some point then neither 5mm if
he takes it on g6 I don't mind that at
all yeah probably a person who knows
this defense much better than I am will
find many situations where my plate can
be criticized if I go bishop efore now
takes i get d fire for the night maybe
this is if you that the e4 porn is
definitely vulnerable but it still I
still think it's maybe worth a shot to
get this activated you see five night is
terribly strong
hmm
and it's really not nice it's really not
nice that manage Bishop g7 at f5 it
would be okay but I have my doubts okay
well now I have 95 at least for some
activity maybe that maybe this isn't so
bad actually check the knight on d5 is
really strong but I am upon down it's
not for compensation I'm not trying to
convey this to some this impression yeah
it's not not great or anything but maybe
I'm I'm still alive in a practical sense
so that there is some some fight left in
the position now I think this is
definitely definitely the case
okay I cannot take it but at the moment
the night is protecting and is
protecting f6
Luke e6 maybe rookie six rookie aid
putting more pressure on the night he
cannot move the night as d4 hangs okay I
don't mind that so much now his his
bashevis is really out of play as long
as long it's not supporting Queen g7
made I mean okay so probably this or
maybe maybe make sure first that there's
a pawn really on you five hm it really
limits my king
but what about this e5 pawn am i winning
this pawn I take it here what is the big
catch I don't see it then Queen g3 or
something like that I am still I'm going
to take it okay so take here check and
she's got this check and possibly Queen
f8 but I can go if I go queen is seven
Quinn a1 + f6 yeah okay yeah i can now
trade and put the night on f5 tracklist
this should it should be quite good
actually yeah and I'm taking h6 and King
age 7 and win the pawn my pawns are
completely preventing the King from
entering
now that's a clean window I just win win
this now this keeps everything closed
you cannot enter on them on the
queenside I mean I could have taken as
well as this is easiest yeah all entries
squares arm time coverage not quite sure
what the point is really okay
and we have 50 seconds on the clock okay
check check white resigns yeah he
definitely had a good position there but
I'm not so sure how good it really is I
mean it is it is looking excellent here
but I'm not so sure I have this
excellent knight on d5 and it's not his
his pony porn at the moment it's not
playing such a such a big role in this
game this d4 pawn I'm really not sure
this looks fairly normal rookie 6 and
what now yeah the computer is also just
giving this is equal and they don't
think that this is any good this is here
I'm really just better this is outside
this is an off-site piece then i win
this pawn I am okay I'm not even playing
it playing it well here check 97's
strong directly going for night f5 it's
even better it also protects the g7 mate
square so there is no nothing like this
yeah i mean i have this chat always have
night at 52 to cover g7 so this was was
even better check but but ok my
continuation should just should win
yeah and wins yeah I think he probably
overestimated this a little bit just my
impression okay thanks for watching